l'environnement et la catastrophe de
tchernobyl c'était il ya 18 ans mais on
s'interroge toujours sur la meilleure
solution
un énorme projet est entré dans sa phase
active il s'agit de recouvrir
entièrement l'ancien sarcophage qui
abrite le réacteur
les entreprises candidates à la
construction viennent de présenter leurs
plans frédéric mentait daniel wolfromm
26 avril 1986 le réacteur numéro 4 de la
centrale ukrainienne de tchernobyl
explose au péril de leur vie
ces hommes enveloppe le réacteur d'un
sarcophage de béton pour limiter les
fuites une construction réalisée en
toute hâte coûtera peines fixées béton
largués par hélicoptère
dix-huit ans après voici l'intérieur du
réacteur avec ces trous béants
l'édifice se fissure la structure
métallique vieillit mal
si rien n'est fait le sarcophage risque
de s'effondrer face au danger plusieurs
entreprises ont été sélectionnées pour
un chantier pharaonique bâtir un dôme
protecteur de 20 mille tonnes tout en
acier aussi grand qu'une cathédrale un
chantier très délicat procès au plus
près de la centrale nucléaire
on peut avoir des temps d'exposition
limité à une heure et justement pour
réduire les doses de radiations les
ouvriers vont assembler le dôme à 200
mètres du réacteur puis le faire glisser
sur des rails
le chantier n'a pas encore commencé que
déjà on s'interroge qui va payer la
facture
elle s'élève à plus de 800 millions
d'euros le g7 en réglera les deux tiers
pour le reste mystère